we're going to begin with the rising
pressure on capitol hill for new gun
laws to address an epidemic of gun
violence in this country
children wore bulletproof vests outside
the capitol to drive home their message
about the need to do something about
guns
and yuvaldi texas native matthew
mcconaughey also visited lawmakers with
his own push for new gun measures a
group of four senators two from each
party is leading the effort to find
compromise or try scott mcfarland is on
capitol hill for us in the middle of it
all scott good morning we've seen
pressure before the question is is there
any progress
tony we know those four senators met
again last night to talk about a
possible bill with provisions for mental
health and for school safety but later
today relatives of those killed in
recent shootings and some high profile
advocates will try to nudge the
negotiations along
after another violent weekend in america
there's mounting pressure for action on
gun laws in the senate
senators please act
don't look away
don't look away
students wearing bulletproof vests also
urge lawmakers in their second week of
negotiations to pass stronger gun laws
this country cannot look away
as our schools and our neighborhoods
become killing fields connecticut
democrat chris murphy who is leading the
bipartisan discussion says he's
optimistic while texas republican john
cornyn laid down a series of red lines
on the senate floor we're not talking
about banning a category of weapons
across the board i'm trying to make
clear that i'm not going to do anything
that violates anybody's second amendment
rights possible areas of agreement could
include helping states enact or improve
their red flag laws which allow courts
to seize guns from anyone deemed
dangerous
as well as taking mental health measures
and increasing school safety funding
actor matthew mcconaughey who's from
uvalde texas joined the calls for
stronger legislation monday on capitol
hill in an op-ed on gun reform he called
for greater background checks and
raising the age to buy an assault rifle
to 21.
saying i believe that responsible
law-abiding americans have a second
amendment right to bear arms i also
believe we have a cultural obligation to
take steps towards slowing down the
senseless killing of our children what
are we supposed to do
with all of this anger with all of this
pain
this morning garnell whitfield jr will
appear before senators his mother ruth
was killed in the shooting rampage at
the buffalo tops grocery store we hope
in some small way to contribute to some
positive change to take this anger
and this hole in our hearts
and make sure it doesn't happen to
somebody else
some states aren't waiting for congress
new york governor kathy hokel three
weeks after the buffalo shooting signed
a slew of new gun measures into law
including one that would raise the age
for purchasing semi-automatic rifles
from 18 to 21. and dana the governors of
delaware and new jersey want their state
legislatures to pass similar bills
compromise never easy scott thank you